[Music]
when I realized that monuments of those
who served our country and fought for
the freedoms that we enjoy today were in
disrepair in poor condition it upset me
it's sad see that they've been forgotten
completely most of them are unreadable
so no one can tell who they are what
they did and how they served our country
and what they meant sarkar if you find a
gleaming stone that may be 100 or 150
years old there's a good chance that
I've probably been there my name is
Andrew Loomis or better known as the
good cemetery in' i restore the
monuments of veterans who served in
multiple conflicts for our country and
their families i complete restorations
on my day off typically which is sunday
i restored between five and six hundred
monuments to date living in the south
there is a multitude of things that
accumulate on a given stone it may have
more than 100 years of buildup and
mildew and mold it's very tedious very
hard work soaking a stone with water
scrubbing with brushes their
toothbrushes and q-tips a monument
restorations typically will take between
2 and 4 months but there's nothing that
makes me feel as good as when I complete
a restoration the reason I began doing
this is for both personal and historical
reasons I have friends who served and
friends who had lost both in battle and
combat and friends who lost their battle
once they came back home it's important
to me to see that they can be remembered
and not forgotten the monuments
themselves are not just stones you know
I want to uncover who they were as a
human being as a person in addition to
their sacrifice in their service to our
country because they weren't just
soldiers either they were Americans
first they were soldiers second I can't
allow that to be forgotten
[Music]